how did you go about researching a video
like that because that's that's such a
yeah where do you start yeah um I so I I
so it originally started on this
Instagram called mcdojo right um and the
third mcdojo is kind of like there was a
lot of like strip mall karate dojos like
in the 80s who would just teach whatever
the [__] and like the big trick is like
the the Sensei the master would always
be like no I can never fight you because
I would kill you you know and it's like
okay and um so like I had done martial
arts with done black belt and Taekwondo
did it for about 10 years and then um I
took up Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I just love
martial arts I love fighting it's fun
and I started watching these videos and
I was like I was just kind of obsessed
with those like this is [__] insane
and I remember I heard one of these
instructors give this like speech to his
students about how it's very important
that I never fight
because it's that would be like bringing
a gun you know and then like I thought
of it I've been doing Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu a little while at this point and I
taught her how many times my instructor
has just beat this [__] so I was like
well this doesn't really add up and um
it was an interesting video I remember
um I got
I got an email after that video from I
don't want to say which martial art it
is because then I'll get a bunch of
comments about it but someone claiming
to be a master in a certain martial art
and he was like here's how a fight
between me and you would go and he
explained step by step everything I do
too
it was like four paragraphs and then I
messaged him back being like okay where
do you want to fight nothing okay
give me a time and a place
yeah because that was like the martial
arts and then there was the psychics as
well right oh the psychics yeah yeah
that was actually that was depressing to
make because it just I I started the
advantage of people yeah like at the
start I was like this is so silly and
then after a while I was like this is
like really praying on like some of the
most sad and hurt people and so I really
wanted to then I thought okay this video
is actually like I should definitely
make this because it was just really
shitty you know but I feel like that's
what happens with a lot of Internet
stuff like that the fake martial arts
and the influencer video they're all
like the same scam you know it's all
finding these people who really want
something and they don't really have a
good grasp on What's Missing from their
own lives yeah and then taking advantage
of it you know yeah I mean that's kind
of how a lot of Cults prey on like you
know vulnerable individuals who are
missing something in their lives uh
because I did actually because I did
watch sure so John made uh a video kind
of like going doing a deep dive into
influencer training courses right yes uh
where you did a bunch of influence
courses and you kind of like tested how
effective they were and I've okay I I'm
really interested in that because did
you see anything that as a YouTuber
yourself you thought was like worthwhile
advice or was it mostly just kind of
like surface level [__] uh Ninja
told me to dye my hair
like no like
you you can't possibly give someone the
specific advice they would need in such
a generic way there's no way so you see
I think the problem is like a lot of
these guys they are incentivized to make
you believe something yeah and if you do
not get those results that's proof that
their [__] doesn't work but then like so
then they develop you know like the
grind set like oh it might not happen
straight away but you know you keep at
it and you keep buying these courses and
it's like it's a very Insidious thing I
think I feel like yeah in terms of like
actual advice I got from it I mean I
thought it was all garbage but I do
understand like I'm kind of an outlier
with a lot of YouTube stuff like I think
if you were to give general advice on
YouTube I probably do none of it and
succeed in spite of myself you know I
mean you can only really give generic
advice to a mass audience you can't
really give no because I feel like
everyone's everyone's journey and
everyone's way of approaching it is so
different and yeah but there actually
was a really interesting video by I
think it was Ludwig yeah and he was like
can I create a viral video from nothing
so I'm not using any of his audio or
anything and he actually did it and so
like there is like a kind of
CounterPoint to something like that but
what I'd say to that is like is it the
one where he sent it to yes yeah I know
but what I'd say is like yeah that's
Ludwig that is one of the most like
creative and intelligent people in terms
of making content he smokes he figured
out that streamers would watch videos if
it's talking about them yeah so he just
paid a streamer a bunch of money to get
it in front of him and of course he's
going to watch it because it's like this
is why this stream is a genius yeah
which is smart because he realizes that
all streamers have he goes which is true
yeah I think it's interesting because uh
I do think there is genuine advice that
you can give to like be more successful
on YouTube kind of Ludwig proved it and
I remember I've seen a video recently of
someone who like tried to make a video
to prove him wrong only for that video
to like blow up so like by taking his
advice uh so you know it generally you
do can do things to like put things in
your core the problem with courses is
that by the time a course is finished uh
and like done it's the like a lot of the
information is probably out of date you
know yeah because YouTube is like
constantly changing and what is relevant
and what works today it's not going to
work like I think six months down the
line absolutely and it's like there's
not stuff you can't do to improve your
chances like you know yeah develop a
good thumbnail develop like a compelling
title structure your video well so that
people want to keep watching it yeah
like it's not the concept I had a
problem with it's the industry that
built up around it yeah yeah it's like
you're seeing some of the videos like
yourself Health books as well it's the
same kind of industrial you know it's
like you can do it sorry I don't have
trouble
did you have another point so I know
that was it okay yeah no I I totally
agree I think it's just like the way it
was my like especially some of the
influences I saw in your video is the
way it was marketed to be like you do
this you'll be guaranteed to make ten
thousand like dollars or you can you
know and especially seeing some of the
ways that the cost breakdown was like
sold to you that I was like they are
being very generous with their numbers
as someone who works in the industry the
X amount of time if you just do that I
feel like ultimately like the test of
that video that none of them ever took
me up on was just like okay release your
actual success rates don't like cherry
pick one person out of like a thousand
show like the actual rate and I said if
it's over 50 I'll delete the video and I
would 100 would yeah never no one ever
took it off of course
I'd be amazed if it was over like one
percent oh yeah yeah completely yeah
because like the thing about being a
successful YouTube I think it's not just
having like one video that blows up it's
being able to like consistently do that
and that's like the [__] hardest that
is the hardest part I genuinely believe
most people have one viral video I I
generally because everyone has that
thing they love that they probably have
a really really interesting Insight you
know yeah I think for me and I'm
probably I consumer you guys as well the
most help I've ever gotten is just from
those camera dudes on YouTube or
lighting people who just give you like
actually to do this put these settings
on your camera I was like that is so
much more helpful than anything else
I've been told because I can you know I
feel like storytelling and that kind of
stuff yes you can be told how to do it
but you really need to actually to do it
and kind of see what they mean like when
you hear all this stuff
you make videos and you kind of get a
feel for that yourself but like actual
technical knowledge that is very helpful
and then like a deep dive into softwares
or stuff that actually just breaks it
down that's all free and available on
YouTube and the best part is is that we
live in an age where if you have a very
very specific problem you can just type
in that exact problem and you will get a
five minute walk through explaining you
how to do it totally and that was so
much more helpful than anything I'd ever
saw of make videos you like be positive
be uh promote yourself Channels with
like 10 subscribers and a foreign accent
you know
yeah somehow like an Indian tutorial
about explaining some like complex
engineering Concepts it was way better
than any of the lectures
they don't know how they do it I was
paying thousands of pounds for that and
some guy injured it for free